اين نشا فيروس كورونا وكيف سؤال تحولت
الاجابه عنه الى جبهه تصريحات مفتوحه
ومتبادله بين الولايات المتحده والصين
واشنطن انحت باللائمه على بخصوص مسؤوليه
انتشار الوباء الذي اوقف عجله العالم عن
الدوران وغير الكثير من القواعد فالجائحه
نتيجه لحادث مختبري في مدينه ووهان
الصينيه وفق مكتب التحقيقات الفيدرالي
الاميركي
لقد قيم مكتب التحقيقات الفيدراليه الان
ان اصول الجائحه هي على الارجح حادث
مختبري محتمل في ووهان كلام اغضب السلطات
الصينيه كثيرا فحسب بكين الولايات المتحده
تتلاعب سياسيا في قضيه اصل فيروس كورونا
الخارجيه الصينيه دعت واشنطن الى احترام
العلوم والحقائق
تعرض الصين بشده اي شكل من اشكال التلاعب
السي في مساله تعقب اصول فيروس كورونا نحث
الجانب الامريكي الاحترام العلم والحقائق
والتوقف عن تسييس قضيه تتبع فيروس كوفيد
تصريحات الجانبين جاءت في اعقاب تقرير
نشرته صحيفه
ليس مبنيا على قدر كبير من الثقه لوزاره
الطاقه الاميركيه قال ان الوباء نتج عن
تسريب غير مقصود من مختبر صيني لتستمر
حكايه اصل الوباء مصدر اتهامات متبادله
بين الشرق والغرب بلال الوجداني العربيه